think story here to explain the
unexplainable I have no tolerance for
the unexplainable
you're not helping Ralph today we're
gonna take a deep dive into HBO's the
outsider examining all its clues as well
as everything we know about the monster
El Coco and you're gonna want to stick
around to the very end as we'll be going
over that mysterious post-credit scene
and what it means so make sure to LIKE
and subscribe because we're ready to
think story as much as the outsider is a
story about solving the murder of a
young child it's equally the story of
one man struggle to believe in the
unbelievable our protagonist Ralph
Anderson is a stubborn detective who
only believes in facts and evidence you
keep your mind open I'm just gonna look
for facts evidence you know dumb cop
[ __ ] like that in fact when he tries to
console glory Maitland the wife of
suspected child murderer Terry Maitland
he tells her whenever I find myself
unable to uncover a reasonable
explanation for a so-called inexplicable
criminal act it only means I haven't
uncovered it yet over the course of the
season Ralph will be confronted with
events that will challenge his worldview
to make him question what is real and
what better way to have one's beliefs
tested than by putting them up against
someone who is the complete opposite
this comes in the form of Holly Gibney
not only is she the opposite physically
being a young african-american female
but her worldview is one of belief that
there are things out there in the world
we can't explain and it's okay to
believe in them she believes in God is
the one who comes up with the l cuoco
theory and unlike ralph is open to
hearing explanations that seem
impossible whereas Ralph please
everything can be explained Holly
believes some things can't and when they
can't be explained the answer is God do
you believe in God of course he's the
explanation explanation for what for
everything in this world that ever
happened to me that I don't understand
that I never will you see Holly herself
is unexplainable she was born with this
tremendous gift of memory being able to
name who was pitching in every game of
the World Series for example or being
able to tell the exact height of a
building just by looking at it her gift
was so inexplicable that scientists
performed
on her as a child there was no
explanation for it
therefore in her mind it was a gift from
God if she can exist why not other
inexplicable things as her investigation
into the murder of Franky Peterson
continues any logical person would be
stumped but not Holly who is able to
expand her sense of reality and believe
perhaps the first step to seeing things
clearly is not to find a way to dismiss
those facts but to expand your sense of
what reality might entail take a look at
Ralph here who face palms in disbelief
when he hears Holly's crazy theory he
hasn't yet completed his character arc
from non-believer to believer but this
will change for Ralph in fact it isn't
until episode 5 exactly halfway through
the season that his worldview begins to
chip away with a visit from his dead son
he of course brushes it off as a dream
just like he brushes off his wife
Jeannie's vision of the hooded man
entering their home for him there must
always be a reasonable explanation
that's why he doesn't even bother having
the chair the hooded man sat in tested
for residue a chair Holly will later
find covered in these same unknown
substance that was found in the barn
were al cuoco transformed in episode 2
from episode 5 onward a series of
unexplainable events happen that shifts
arauz worldview
for example the drawing about cuoco by
his wife and the young boy who also saw
him or Holly's theories how the monster
operates coming true and the eventual
attempted murder of Holly by Jack who
and what L cuoco is is at the core of
how Holly and the other investigators go
about trying to stop it in episode 6
Holly explains her findings that an
entity shall call al cuoco based off
Latin American folklore is the cause of
a string of child murders it needs to
feed every 24 to 27 days in order to
gain its strength preferring young
children because is a taste sweetness
after it kills however it must shed its
skin like a snake and transform making
it extremely weak and vulnerable it will
use a slave like Jack or Tracy to
perform certain errands for it while
it's in this vulnerable state Aaron's
like collecting lamps and food these
quote-unquote slaves are not to be
confused with the beings it transforms
into like Terry or Claude the difference
being that the doppelganger
can only be created via direct contact
as in blood which manifests itself in
the show through scratching Maria
Canales a woman convicted of killing a
young boy scratches heath Hofstetter who
goes on to kill two young girls then he
goes to scratch Terry Maitland who kills
Frankie Peterson who in turn scratches
claw it's Holly who discovers that the
time in between these murders is about
24 to 27 days leading her to believe
that's the cycle this entity uses to
feed the slaves on the other hand are
weak individuals who have a history of
immense pain which L cuoco feeds off and
can manipulate jack is the perfect
candidate his wife left him he's a drunk
who had an overbearing mother and had
spent his entire life training to be a
sniper only to fail his final psych
evaluation never being able to fulfill
his dream Jack struggles throughout the
season trying to fight the entity that's
taking control of him but eventually
succumbs to its will ikuko doesn't just
take a child victim it likes to take its
entire family and feed off its grief it
likes to linger all that grief down
there he's the perfect example of this
is the Peterson family after the death
of Frankie mrs Peterson suffers some
sort of stroke and dies
this leads Ollie to shoot Terry which
leads to Ali's death and eventually mr.
Peterson the only one left to hang
himself the death of one spiraled into
the death of the entire family and L
cuoco feeds off this it's drawn to pain
pain is a it's wine if L cuoco doesn't
feed he gets weak which is shelter his
gradual physical decline as seen through
the series of drawings done by Merlin
and Janine in the final episode our
investigators have tracked down L cuoco
in a cave that collapsed back in 1947
trapping and killing more than 34 Souls
remember that L cuoco loves to rest up
in locations where there is a lot of
grief and sim previously choosing the
barn that's near a graveyard he has
taken on the form of Claude Bolton a
former proprietor of the peach crease
strip club and knows the others are on
their way you see L cuoco has the
ability to know the thoughts of the
person he has taken over and stupid seal
Bolton clods brother let it slip they
were on their way in a tragic twist of
irony the man who dreamed of being a
sniper uses his sniper skills to kill
Holly's love interest and he cut cabbage
Alec Pelle and Howard Solomon before
killing himself Holly and Ralph go on to
investigate the cave and Holly notes
that L cuoco can probably be killed a
question she and the others have often
asked noting that it's residue can be
found along the handrails going down
into the cave her reasoning is that an
entity that isn't scared would likely
not be holding on to the rails deeper
into the cave past the corpses of eaten
animals and the names of those who died
in the collapse they finally come
face-to-face with L cuoco he's curious
how holly was able to find out about him
and not only that convince others to
this hints that this entity has been
around for quite some time completing
this cycle over and over again
Holly even asked him if there are others
like him to which he says he can sense
there are more but doesn't know for sure
the predicament they find themselves in
is that they can't use their firearms
the cave is extremely unstable and any
loud noises could trigger a collapse of
course the real Claude comes ambling in
and does exactly that
shooting l cuoco in triggering a cave-in
as the dust settles Holly Ralph and the
real Claude stumble out Holly even looks
over the body of the seemingly dead L
cuoco and says a very weird line in
response to Ralph saying that Terry can
now be exonerated
she says who's Terry remember that her
memory
is amazing and this just goes to show
you that the hunt for El Coco has
totally consumed her and she's forgotten
what she was hired to do in the first
place to clear Terry's name as they make
their way out Ralph decides to go back
he's also briefly visited by the ghosts
of his son and that of Olly almost as if
they're looking at him to finish the job
because el Coco isn't dead
Ralph ends up smashing el cuccos face in
opting not to turn him into some
scientific experiment to be prodded by
scientists but before he does el Coco
shape ships in multiple different forms
luckily the people he had shifted into
from his past we also get this slow
dolly in on what appears to be the
hoodie belonging to el Coco which he
used throughout the season
Holly Ralph and the others also decide
to get their story straight so that when
they're questioned about what really
went down here there aren't any holes in
their story and Terry's name can be
exonerated after all who would believe
an unbelievable tale about shapeshifters
the Georgia DA can if Hays tells glory
that her husband has been exonerated due
to the new developments in the case but
what I find more interesting is this
short scene in episode 9 where he's
informed a young boy was found naked and
mauled just like Frankie Peterson was
but apparently el Coco was busy
transforming into Claude at this time
and going after kids in Tennessee not
Georgia even though I know Georgia and
Tennessee are right next to each other
this is the biggest hint that there are
other el cuccos out there but I'm also
where it is possible it could be the
same one jeannie ends up burning the
chair el coco left his residue on as a
final fu she also tells Lori that she
probably shouldn't mention the whole
supernatural stuff when she's questioned
since it might interfere with her
husband's exoneration and finally Ralph
says goodbye to Holly and says he'd like
to work with her again he's now a full
believer in things that sometimes never
make sense Holly goes on to say how el
Coco asked her how she was open to
believing his existence saying an
outsider knows an outsider she herself
has been an outsider her whole life she
knows that what seems unbelievable is
possible because she exists a woman who
can remember everything Ralph
also opens up to his wife about seeing
Derek their son something he would have
never done previously he even says maybe
next time
he appears it'll be the real Derrick the
Ralph from episode 1 would never have
believed that to be possible they leave
a rose on their son's grave as we fade
out on the grave of Frankie Peterson who
is also buried in the same Cemetery and
whose death sparked the events of this
entire season bringing things full
circle and I hope you stayed around for
the post-credits scene which sees Hawley
experience a vision of Jack the man who
murdered her love and checking to see if
she has a rash on the back of her neck
but while she's checking her laptop to
see how things are going in the Peterson
case three really weird things happen
first the scratch on her arm hinting
that she was scratched by al cuoco and
will become the next victim now we never
see how she got it and in the scene
where she's saying goodbye to Ralph she
does not have this scratch so it would
have to have been after the events in
the cave second and really mysterious is
that the shot here is done in Reverse
I'll try to play it a few times but
there is no logical explanation for why
it would be done this way
finally the song that comes on the radio
is Washington Square the same song Ralph
told Holly about that played on the day
of his son's birth and his mother's
death 15 years apart something Holly
said was just a coincidence to me this
ending has nothing to do with whether
holly is some sort of new el cuckoo or
not but fits in with the broader theme
of the show which is believing the
unbelievable and how we make sense of
the unexplainable
we can't rationally explain with
evidence and logic why she was cut why
that song plays or why it's in Reverse
because it can't be explained rationally
the show is testing us in this final
scene are we going to look at it with
facts and logic like Ralph or will we
need to expand our reality like Holly in
order to explain the unexplainable
that's the point of this final scene
which way do you see it thanks everyone
for watching please make sure to give
the video a like and subscribe I'm
always coming out with
new videos you can also follow me on
Twitter at the story YT until next time
remember daddy loves you very much